several marijuana dispensaries really
eager to learn more about the future of
consumption lounges right here in
southern nevada so marijuana consumption
lounges were made legal last year but
now the state is trying to iron out all
those regulations joe moeller is live
near desert inn and sammy davis junior
drive with what's set to happen tomorrow
joe
the cannabis compliance board is working
on the rules and regulations for these
cannabis consumption lounges the next
workshop public is invited to is
happening tomorrow tomorrow afternoon
that is but meanwhile dispensaries
around the valley like planet 13 here
are eager to get these lounges open
just wait a game planet 13 has been
working on what will be their marijuana
consumption lounge this allows us to not
only create the products here and sell
the products here but for people to
consume the products consumption lounges
were made legal last year but now the
state is working on all the rules david
ferris is the vice president of sales
and marketing at planet 13. he says they
can't wait to open a lounge right now
we're waiting kind of finalization of
what the lounge bill looks like and what
those requirements will be so we can you
know create something within that
framework come tuesday the next step in
the regulation making process will take
place the whole point of a workshop is
to be able to solicit feedback from
members of the public members of the
industry and members of local
governments tyler klimas is the
executive director of the cannabis
compliance board he says tuesday they
will further discuss a variety of
regulations some of those rules include
air quality regulation and lounge
employee training once we finish
promulgating these regulations by the
board we'll move to actually issuing a
license for consumption lounges or we'll
likely see some consumption lounges open
by the end of the year clemens says so
far 45 dispensaries have expressed an
interest in opening a lounge we get
asked you know
hourly on is there a lounge here when it
will be here ferris says nevada is
paving the way i think a lot of other
states even going from medical to
recreational are really watching las
vegas to see how we handle it
back out here live that meeting or the
workshop is set to take place tomorrow
at the grant sawyer building at one
o'clock that's just north of downtown
las vegas at las vegas boulevard in
washington now they expect the first
lounge to be open come fall reporting
live near near the strip joe muller live
local now